all right so let's start with today's
webinar hello everyone a very warm
greeting to one and all my name is
Krishna Kumar and I would like to
welcome you all for today's webinar on
health informatics Health informatics is
a rapidly growing field that involves
collecting and analyzing Healthcare data
and creating new job opportunities where
computers and care providers work
together it's pretty closely related to
the field of Public Health and with the
increasing use of big data analytics in
the healthcare field the demand for
health informatics jobs is predicted to
increase over the next decade
considering the scope and degree of
complexity in health informatics we have
designed the machine learning for health
informatics program to skill up
individuals who may come from the
healthcare as well as data science
domain and in today's webinar we are
joined by Dr Jeet sarkar senior
bioinformatics scientist at illustrator
who will be introducing the participants
to the field of healthcare informatics
this will be followed by sharing of
program details and the registration
process
so before we begin with today's webinar
let me also take a brief moment to
introduce you to the team behind the
program
we are a us-based bandformatics company
who is working with multiple academic
and Commercial collaborators to develop
easy to use analytical tools and our
mission is to make bioinformatics more
accessible
and as a part of the program students
will have access to the omics logic
training that has been completed by over
24 000 participants from 187 countries
in over 300 workshops and due to this
fast goal our team is working with local
and Regional coordinators that are
helping refine local program Logistics
and adapting them to the needs of
students and researchers around the
world and this training has been
completed by participants in six
different specialization tracks that
includes oncology infectious diseases
Precision medicine Neuroscience data
science for biomedical data and
comprehensive training on omic's data
analysis
students will also have access to the
omics logic resources but how does it
help Advance bioinformatics teaching
omic's logic is a portal for practical
and theoretical learning of
bioinformatics it takes a combination of
training modules data analysis tools
curated project data sets and
interactive sessions with mentors to
give the student a clear path of the
Bloom's taxonomy pyramid and no matter
what the user's initial experience with
bioinformatics is omox logic is a useful
tool for gaining a baseline knowledge of
the theory behind bioinformatics like
are in python or even beginning a data
analysis project this also comes with an
access to the omix logic courses which
includes courses on bioinformatics
Precision medicine multi elements that
includes genomics transcriptomics
metagenomics and epigenomics data
science that includes bioinformatics
using R and python as well as chem
informatics and example projects of
different fields which you could learn
from and replicate for your research
work and the users will be given
directions to access the key by info
platform for bioinformatic processing
and Analysis of data and the platform
includes demo pipelines as well as data
management and Analysis Cloud
infrastructure to run the bioinformatic
pipelines and different stages of
analysis are performed in different
sections on the small Dynamics platform
to view the various courses example
projects student projects you need to
first sign up on the omics logic learn
portal before that let me walk you
through a brief demo on what a completed
profile on the portal looks like
so once you sign up on the portal these
are the features that you need to update
on your account that is a completed
profile will have a profile image full
name with appropriate capitalization
link to your social media handles a
brief bio about yourself
the mentors can view your progress under
the activity tab the courses you are
currently completing will appear under
the core system finally after the
completion of your course the
certificates will appear under the
certificate step and so with that let us
Begin by signing up only omixological
and portal
so here I'm sharing the link to the
portal in the chat box so those of you
who have not signed up on the portal
please visit the link and I will through
the demo on how to sign up on the portal
so for those of you who are new and want
to create an account on the portal
please click on the create an account
option that you see here so once you
click on you will be asked to enter your
name email address and password or you
can also sign up using any of your
social media accounts that is Google
Facebook Apple account GitHub account or
even Twitter and for those participants
who already have an account on the
portal you can simply click on the login
now option and simply sign in so I'll
pause for a couple of seconds so that
the participants can sign up on the
portal and once you have signed up
please put a yes in the chat box so that
I can know that I can proceed further
and for those of you who already have an
account on the pro today you can simply
leave a done in the chat box so that I
can know
um that as well
and if you're having any queries along
the way you can share that as well and
I'll be happy to guide you
so I'm expecting responses from the
um 15 plus participants that are there
all right so I'm just going to proceed
ahead and sign up but along the way if
you're having any queries please feel
free to share in the chat box so once
you sign in you will be able to view the
various courses and example projects
that are there on the portal so for to
uh find out any specific course you can
simply enter the keyword that you're
looking for such as machine learning and
that will give you all the courses and
example projects that makes use of this
concept
and now coming to the part where you
have to update your account on the
portal you can simply click on the tab
that says welcome back with your email
ID and here you will be uh you'll see a
icon that says profile so once you click
on that you can edit all the necessary
details that I mentioned in this slide
that is your bio profile image name with
appropriate capitalization and link to
your social media handles and as
mentioned previously the community
manager and the mentor of the program
will be tracking your learning progress
under the activity test and the courses
that you are currently completing will
appear under the courses Tab and once
you complete a project and upload it on
the portal it will be displayed under
the project staff and once you enroll
for any of the programs such as machine
learning for health informatics that
will be displayed under the programs Tab
and once you complete the required
courses course assignments and quizzes
the certificates will appear under the
certificate
so with that
um if the participants have no further
queries let us move on to the next part
of today's webinar
so for that I'd like to give the
participants a brief uh introduction to
today's speaker that is Dr Jeet sarkar
Dr Ajit sarkar is a physician scientist
the Keen interest in data analytics and
precision medicine he is passionate
about finding meaning out of biomedical
data and leveraging them for better
clinical outcomes his work generally
involves offering meaningful and
translational guidance to biological and
Healthcare organizations currently
working as senior bioinformatics
scientists I'm sure we will be able to
learn a lot about the field and
opportunities from him and with that now
I'd like to pass on the stage to Dr
sukkah the stage is all yourself
and thanks
so let me share my screen
yes
I guess it's visible
yes
so hello guys
today's webinar would mainly cover the
course content which we will be offering
from Jan next year so the course is
named as machine learning in health
informatics
we will be having two parts of the
course one is the theoretical
understandings followed by some Hands-On
training
so today the course content will be
covering mainly the topics and the
topics details which we will cover in
the coming
three months in the course
so just to introduce me I myself I am
trained I was trained as a clinical
graduate basically a clinician then I
shifted my career towards the domain of
bioinformatics and health informatics
data analytics and now what I do is I
combine multiple data types to build
predictive models ml based models for a
specific clinical outcome
these covers use cases from the hospital
based organizations from the drug
Discovery companies
for the life insurance providers
so for today's webinar I have kept it in
three particular subsections first I
will cover the overview of Health
informatics which we will be teaching in
this particular course
then I will briefly work through the
types of Health informatics data and
lastly I will cover the case study
structure which we will be following in
the
course
so overview of Health informatics so the
first slide is how
informatics is transforming Healthcare
in this particular
stage of AI and machine learning so as
you can see there are mainly three broad
categories of Health informatics
the first is patient care
the next major thing is business process
and management the third one is drug
Discovery and
companies called Pharmaceuticals
so for the domain of patient care
Health informatics can be used to solve
problems where we can manage efficiently
appointments clinical visits awaiting
duration to the clinic we can have
precise diagnostics for particular
diseases we can prevent diseases by
detecting them at an earlier stage
one important thing is patient triage so
a hospital would be containing suppose
thousand patients we need to stratify
them into high risk moderate risk or low
risk and this triage is very important
for patient care so this strategy is
also done based on informatics and
lastly Imaging and diagnostic
city scan images extra images any
biomarker Discovery all these things
also fall in under the purview of Health
informatics
for the business process and management
there is something called process
automation so in business so generating
business reports generating interactive
and flexible reports is something which
we are which is also a very useful use
case
claims Administration that involves
mainly predicting
the cost of or the burden of patient
or the high risk patients from the past
claims history medical claims history so
that that is very important from the for
the industry of healthcare claims
customer churn so what is the footfall
in your particular Clinic
when does the footfalls increase in
which month of the year
what are the factors that increases so
these things also fall in the purview of
business management then chatbot and
lastly business insights
for the drug Discovery companies or
Pharmaceuticals the majority is drug
Discovery so identifying drug targets so
by identifying molecular targets Gene
targets
planning Logistics planning and lastly
improving clinical trials so which
clinical trial how can we manage
clinical trials more efficiently so
these things fall under the purview of
direct Discovery and pharmaceuticals so
these are the major three three
Industries
where
informatics is actually transforming the
healthcare
gradually
so so what do we provide so if I just
try to bucket the solutions so I talked
about the problem now now if I come to
the solutions so what are the solutions
informatics based Solutions which are
there in the health care domain so I
have just mentioned six major categories
the first one is prediction
so prediction is actually predicting a
clinical outcome or any outcome from
some
particular predictors or features
the next part is cluster identification
so suppose we have
a cluster of patients now we want to
identify that which cluster is a high
risk Group which is a Lotus Group which
is a moderate risk group so these things
also we can do using the AI based
techniques
nowadays there is a very
trend of using fitbits and variables
which help us stream
real-time data blood pressure data and
pulse data so all these things we use
time series modeling for prediction so
for to predict
a clinical outcome predict uh
sudden clinical outcome so these things
we
do using time series Analytics
then there is something called image
analytics so for image we have cities
can image we have extra images so all
these things we also use informatics for
the purpose
lastly we have also a clinical nodes so
OCR is a very important technique which
we use for informatics
so in case of OCR we actually scan
clinical nodes Hamilton nodes extract
the information from there then apply
nnp based techniques to generate
insights may be the most frequently
occurring diseases or the most frequent
complaint and all these things and this
also falls under the domain of
informatics lastly we can combine these
major solutions to build up customized
Solutions
so if so I just gave three particular
more specific use cases so we can
identify cancer subtypes for more
precise therapy because as you know that
cancer is a disease where some persons
are respond to chemotherapy some don't
respond some respond to a particular
drug regimen some don't respond so if we
can detect the cancer subtypes that can
that can help us to
to inject a particular specific drug
regimen which is known as prevention
therapy that is also done using health
informatics
we can detect and classify tumors from
x-ray image and CT scan and lastly a
very interesting thing is mental health
nowadays and by using social network
posts by using NLP we can detect mental
health problems
so this is a overview of the modeling
which we use for health informatics
so the first of all we do have multiple
types of data so
being
being able to explore the data types
having a know-how of how they look
but to find them how to structure them
how to
make them very simple for predictive
purpose so that's a very big challenge
in health informatics so we generally
have electronic health records we have
wireless devices we have medical devices
clinical notes there are multiple types
of data sources now all these data
sources have to be converted into a
machine readable format for modeling
purpose so this is a very important area
of healthcare data and this requires
lots of expertise and
insight to do that so the first step is
data preparation from this multiple data
sources
after data preparation we can bucket
them into specific
subgroups demographic features comorbit
conditions surveys vitals like that and
those things we can input to our
training set for our for the model
training and we can use them to predict
a particular clinical outcome and we
will also test it into a different and
independent set and we can use it in
that fashion now as new data comes in
the training would become more and more
precise and the model would get updated
accordingly so this is a very general
overview of modeling so I just wanted to
mention it so we will be using multiple
types of modeling we will be learning
multiple modeling techniques in the
course
more specific and of course we will also
be doing some very Hands-On hands-on
experience from our example data set and
predicting the condition from
ourselves
so any questions so far
no sir it looks like no one has any
query so far but uh if the participants
are having any queries along the way
please feel free to share it in the chat
and we'll be happy to answer
so we can proceed
okay
so now I will go to the
very high level understanding of the
health informatics data types
so there are multiple types of data and
actually you can imagine every sort of
biomedical data biotech data Healthcare
data
free clinical notes
social network posts Facebook posts
Twitter post everything can be used in
the context of healthcare informatics
even the
dietary your dietary intake the the uh
the dietary level of the chip switch you
take or any fast food so everything
everything and anything is actually can
be used to build
very important use cases for health
informatics
but I will cover the most frequent and
mostly used things so the first of it is
emrs so what are emrs emrs are actually
electronic medical records so it's like
in majority of the countries we that
they have implemented the EMR so instead
of capturing all the clinical nodes we
have the digitized format so those emrs
are actually a Content structured and
semi-structured data and these EMR is a
very rich source of healthcare data
next is medical images so images can be
x-ray CT scan MRI so these are mainly
static images we can also have video
images of suppose fetal scan and Fetal
anomalies can endoscope EU bronchoscopy
so all sort of image and videos this
fall under the domain of medical images
and these for for medical image analysis
we do need a very specific set of skills
and specific set of
algorithms which mainly fall under the
domain of computer vision so computer
vision is what drives Medical Imaging
and medical image classification
next is histopathology so actually our
body is consists of organs tissues and
cells so microscopic tissue tissue
sections are is what we call as
histology so and uh microscopic
appearance of a particular tissue in
case of a disease versus in case of a
healthy person is different so
identifying those microscopic
differences by using machine learning
techniques is what falls under the
pathological Health informatics
lastly all all students who come from
the biotic domain we know multi-ohmics
data so multi-oh mix contains genomics
transcriptomics proteomics and
metabolomics there are also other omics
data so and this High throughput data of
genomics and mass mass spectrometry
these are also used for
Health informatics cases so nowadays
people are talking about Precision
therapy in cancer in cancer you profile
the particular tissue you profile the
particular
genomic
structure of the tissue you you profile
it using single cell transcriptomics you
find out the main Gene sweeter perturbed
for that for that patient and you give
them a very precise drug as per that
particular Gene profile
next is epidemiological data so
epidemiology actually consists of
population level data so socioeconomic
background education public health
conditions what is the literacy what is
the socioeconomic status how many cars
do I own what is my lifestyle
and these All Things fall under the
category of economical data and actually
from this data we can find out very very
useful insights of multiple diseases so
we can so suppose in the context of
kovit we can find out that which are the
main geographical con Pockets from which
kovit is more
concentrated
in the in the context of any lifestyle
disease we can tell that in which
particular population whether it male or
female or males from which particular
part of the country they are more prone
to develop diabetes
and other diseases so this helps us to
detect population level insights so that
we can change the public health policy
accordingly and they are also used
informatics
then I already mentioned about time
series data these are mainly data live
streaming data coming from fitbits and
variables like Apple watch or a Samsung
watch like that and from that we can
predict time series analysis and we can
predict a particular event which is
going to come so in the context of
giatric population there is one
important use case called fall
prediction so basically geriatric people
tend to fall very often because of the
blood pressure so as for the blood
pressure suddenly drops down so if we
can predict from the
past records of blood pressure that this
person is going to have the blood
pressure gradually dropping down and
these and hence an impending fall so we
can
maybe give an alert or a notification of
the particular person and the concerned
healthcare workers or the relatives to
tell that this person is going to have a
particular fall and actually fall
incidents do cause a huge burden on the
Healthcare System
in the west as well as in the east so
it's a very important use case fault for
the healthcare organizations
so clinical notes so actually emrs are
not yet
implemented in majority of the countries
we till we still have clinical notes and
these clinical notes are actually they
they are there in sort of silos they are
isolated they are not usable for the
informatics or inside generation so we
have to convert the clinical nodes to a
digital format now this conversion of
clinical nodes to digital format we use
something called OCR now after OCR we
use something called natural language
process called NLP this OCR NLP helps us
to extract clinical note into digital
format and then provide insights and
lastly social network data so you can do
sentiment analysis from Twitter posts
that this person is having this
sentiment as detected by their multiple
posts over the last six months so that
can cause so that tells me that this
person is a high risk for a depression
and maybe a suicide so these so suicide
detection and all the mental health
problems this we can do from the
uh these sort of data
so again so this variety of data and
combining all sorts of data into the by
data specific format for a particular
prediction or inside generation this is
what health informatics consists of and
we will be going to have a very good
understanding of this particular thing
in the course and we will be going to
discuss two to three case studies in
this course and also with the Hands-On
session
so now the challenges so I told that the
challenge majorly is in data quality and
infrastructure so data is in different
formats across different
countries across different spaces so we
we have to if we want to combine data if
we if we want to do uh do a
meta-analysis we have to structure data
in the same format so this data cleaning
and data structuring is a very big
problem and challenge for physical
informatics
next is data collection so data
collection is very very
restricted and very very well sort of
maintained called and governed for
healthcare data because it can be used
for it can be misused for different
cases
and last the data science skills the
skill set and at least a good amount of
expert people with with this skill set
is truly lacking in the health
informatics industry and given the
growth of healthcare data in the coming
decades
that is going to be a very
very extensive requirement of Health
informatics skill set and that's what
actually this program
aims to cover to develop this Knowledge
and Skills of various data sources and
data types followed by a Hands-On
learning
with a few use cases
so now I will just cover the last slide
it's the case study structure
so as I told we will be implementing and
we will be teaching two use cases two
case studies in this particular session
the first thing we will be introducing
the participants the case study
we will discuss the background of the
case study
and the objective of the case study
next we will
give you a clean data we will tell you
how to
look at the data data overview
the next part is the data exploration so
you will be importing the data into your
particular notebook and they will
explode it
this is something called Eda or
expressed data analysis
next part is model building so once we
explore the data we will select that
which is the target variable that which
variable we want to predict and which
are the predictors so features which we
will be using for the
prediction
and lastly the model so there are
different types of model as I have told
supervised model unsupervised model in
the supervised model multiple different
regression and random products is an XG
boost and your networks so we will be
discussing some of them and we will be
discussing about one particular model
and after we have built the model we
will do the model validation so our
model works good in the context of a
known data suppose I know 10 students
and I know that in these 10 students
those two are actually good good
performers and those eight are not good
performance so if you tell me to predict
the score of these two these 10 students
in the final exam I can play it very
well
because I know that they are they are
good and they are not that much good so
modern validation is where you take a
model and you use the model to predict
the Unknown People
those people whom I don't know
so this is called modern validation and
from there we can have some Matrix
called accuracy sensitivity and
specificity there are also other Matrix
so this Matrix helps us to gauge the
model
uh the model accuracy and the model
validation
lastly there is something called
interpretable AI so
just I would say just be one decade back
we were very focused into building
models building machine learning models
doing some predictions and if a model is
90 percent 80 percent 85 percent
accurate people are very happy with that
but
in the case of healthcare informatics
only your model performance is not going
to convince the Physicians or any
healthcare provider to use it
you have to provide them proper
interpretation and this is called as
explainable or interpretable AI so you
have to tell the clinician or the
healthcare worker that my model has
predicted that this person is actually a
high risk patient
and my model tells that this person
contains these features and because the
person contains these features that's
why it's a high
release patient so we have to explain
the model internal logic to the
clinician and that is where we use
interpretable AI or model interpretation
so we will also briefly talk about the
interpretable AI in the course
so this is the base case study structure
so again just to summarize we we will be
discussing about the theoretical
understanding we will be discussing
about the different data sources called
Health informatics
we will be discussing about the
different solutions for health
informatics
and lastly we will download one
particular data set and we will use we
will give you a Hands-On training for
two particular case studies from
Healthcare informatics domain
ah and we will also work to the model
building and validation and modeling
repetition
so that's all for today I guess if there
are some questions I can take them up
thank you so much
so uh we have one query in the chat uh
the first one is Harish is asking what
are the pre-processing steps
okay
so so in this case uh for our course we
will be giving you very clean data
but yes as you have told correctly so if
data is not clean then we actually do
some
data imputation based on the particular
case so suppose we are having we are
doing a case control study and we do
have some information for some rows in
that case we can do a group by
imputation
for pre-processing suppose our all the
features are not normalized so if we
build a model then the role of one
feature would be so massive
the coefficient of one feature would be
so massive that it would not allow the
other coefficients to express themselves
in that case we have to do some sort of
data scaling
the last thing is another thing is
feature selection so before model
building there is something called
feature selection and that's a very
important thing and feature selection
again depends on the model which we are
building
to tell in simple terms suppose we are
using a simple linear regression model
in that case we can use first exploited
data analysis to find out which features
are show some
significant difference in the model
output we can select them there are
other approaches called Information Gain
approaches which tells you that this is
the top features which should be
selected
there's something called Mutual
Information Gain
and but if the model is a very difficult
model Suppose there are some there is
one category of model called mixed
effect regression model in that case
also we have to do the presentation in a
very uh in a very totally in a very
customized path pattern but yes
feature selection data processing is a
big Challenge and again it depends on
the data type suppose if you are doing
some image processing in that case that
would be a different challenge if you
are doing some NLP based thing so now
NLP problem Can Can Depend from question
answering problem
any other problem then there are
different type of problems so depending
on the particular problem you have to
proceed with the data preparation I
guess in this particular course because
it's a general course for everybody we
will be focusing on limiting ourselves
to a very particular two case studies
but we also do have something called
mental guided program in that case you
can come with your own use cases and we
can maybe work through those solve them
very minutely in a one-to-one manner
uh thank you sir I hope your query got
answered Harish and uh UF has raised his
hand you know what would you like to ask
your query
okay yeah thank you for the presentation
and it was quite insightful
um but I have a problem with um one of
the uh the approaches what you just
finished discussing because in the real
world
um
um they are going to be giving us Mercy
data and um we in in the course for
example you said we're going to get
clean data and um we might not actually
get the exact skill set to be able to
deal with
um some um some of the kind of the some
of the different kind of datas that we
will get so
um what I'm trying to say is wouldn't it
be appropriate for for you to actually
walk us through like the mercy kind of
data because the goal of for me is to
get the real like to get a job right and
um live in that face of which is very
very important in the model training out
of the equation will actually
um kind of make my learning process not
effective so that's basically my my own
take that if it is possible
um can you guys make it that will have
data that we can do this Eda do some
pre-processing with your guidance and
see how it works thank you
yes so um just to answer your question
uh so I guess it was wobna
the question came from
first second session we will be
introducing you to at least
30 data sources these are all open
source data sources
as you have mentioned we will also
introduce you you to the multimodal data
resources and there are some clean
sources there are some unclean and very
dirty sources
now for the sake of the common common
syllables we do have to keep we would
have to adjust the
um
what do I say the the level to uh to a
sort of a middle standard where people
from different sources can can go
through it but yes we uh do have that
thing also in our mind and I guess
that's also from the Mind biotech team
that because now these coils are coming
out we can maybe modulate a few sessions
or for a complex case and just walk
through a very complex dirty data how to
clean the data and if you have something
on on your mind you can also do for the
by other mentorship program to give you
a more Hands-On useful training for
handling dirty and messy data
thank you
well thank you so much Julia and then we
have another query from Dr Ghazal uh
what about feature selection and
dimensionality reduction
yes so uh Dr Ghazal as slowly taught
pulled about feature selection so future
selection we would be talking uh in this
particular course
so and the two case studies in one case
study we will cover the supervised
learning in the other case study we will
cover the answer of this learning
so dimensional reduction techniques we
will talk about in the second course and
we will uh briefly then I will introduce
the PCA
if time permits I will also try to
introduce the tsne and view map
components and again uh so because these
are very specific use cases suppose now
one person wants to have a Hands-On on
dimensional reduction one person or
multimodal uh learning somebody else on
pre-processing and so I guess the best
best route would be to go through go to
a mentor guided one one-on-ones one
session from that we can take on this
particular courses and particular use
cases and solve them accordingly
oh thank you so much Dr sarkar so I
guess uh if the participants are having
any queries please share it in the chat
all right uh thank you Dr Ghazal
yeah
all right so
if there are no more queries
um you'd like to move on to the next
part so thank you so much Dr sarkar for
joining today's webinar and answering
the participants queries
and uh with that now I'd like to invite
Miss special to discuss about the
program details and the registration
process so over to use bush
session
it was very interesting so let me share
my screen
um shrigori could you please confirm if
you can see my screen if it's visible
yes it is visible
perfect
so hello everyone uh my name is parshdar
and I am the marketing manager here at
finding biotech so I'll be quickly
guiding you through the registration
part the resources which you have access
to when you'll be a part of this program
and then the pricing and the scholarship
so as you can see that the name of the
program is machine learning for health
informatics case based learning and it's
in collaboration with Dr Jeet sarkarin
obviously a company Pine biotech and the
program is going to commence on 11th
January 2023
so as we are as we move further
so you can see the program overview
so if one would enroll in this
particular program so we you will learn
to utilize medical informatics data by
applying machine learning aspects and
how this data science and machine
learning aspects uh is imparting a
positive impact on the patient and
physician relationship then the second
is the mentor guidance so the guidance
of we you'll be having guidance from
industry and academic mentors to apply
Health informatics and solve various
case based questions problem there would
be q a sessions there would be
one-on-one Mentor sessions Etc now in
this particular program we will be
helping the participants to
transitioning from the beginner level to
an advanced level by going through with
some of the topics uh as data
acquisition data structuring workflow
selection cross validation for
healthcare technical data analysis Etc
and now comes the most important part
that is the analysis of the data types
so the participants would be learning
from different data sources in health
informatics like electronic health
records diagnostic test results medical
scans and biomedical data and their
integration for healthcare research
after the program is over so obviously
you might have a question that what
would be the opportunities what like how
we'll get a career a guidance if there
is a certificate or not so definitely
our industry and academic mentors would
help you guide you how you can further
uh you know collaborate and increase
your networking with other mentors in
the same field how uh like there would
be 24 into 7x support from the omics
logic team whether it's technical or the
mentor guidance and uh then they will
guide you how how there are different
job opportunities in this particular
field how you can apply in different job
opportunities based on your skills
requirement the job description Etc
so um this all would be covered in short
now when you scroll down you can see a
interactive sessions like a calendar and
here it's like you will see some
highlighted dates when we'll be
conducting all these sessions and on the
right hand side or maybe your left hand
side of your laptop side so there are
list of the sessions which we'll be
covering throughout the program
throughout the tenure of the program so
the first session that we'll be
commencing is on January 11th it's the
introduction to the program and here are
the topics like um AI in transforming
Healthcare investments in AI for
healthcare how data science is
transforming uh Healthcare the
challenges in the health informatics
predictive model workflow multi-model
approach for precision medicines and
obviously there would be a q a session
following this first session the second
session is on data sources then uh the
third would be example one over View and
then the data analysis conclusions
example to overview data and Analysis so
it would be a based it would be totally
based on case-based learning and side by
side we'll be covering topics like
clustering uh clustering clustering
techniques post clustering tasks then uh
clinical implications of clustering
other possible use cases clinical
relevance product development real world
applications Etc so this is uh this was
a brief about the curriculum and when
you scroll down you will see there are
three different tenures in which you
could be a part of and uh the first is
45 days second is the 60 days and third
is the 90 days so there are some of the
common resources which uh everyone would
have access to in all the three tenures
that is online tutorials project
examples coding sessions session
recordings online Mentor Support Online
technical support and obviously the
certificate after the completion of the
program and then we have a t bioinfo
server so you would have access to the
demo pipelines of uh those three by info
server for the analysis part also now
what's the difference between the three
in these 60 days tenure you will have
two different opportunities one is the
one-on-one Mentor sessions so for
example uh while going through with the
session you got stuck somewhere you want
to clarify your doubts and queries with
the mentor we can organize a one-on-one
exploratory made of yours with the
mentor and you can get your queries and
questions clarified and the second is
after your 45 days of training is over
the rest of the 15 days you'll be
devoting towards preparing a proper
research proposal an experimental design
so so how whatever you have learned like
a conceptual and theoretical basis on
conceptual and theoretical basis how you
can apply it in a real life application
so definitely our Elementor that is Dr
Jeet sakal he would help you he'll uh
evaluate your research proposal he'll
see if there are any changes that need
to be done he'll guide you accordingly
and then you can move further by
developing your independent research
project also
so
um and in the 90 days again you have two
opportunities with one-on-one Mentor
sessions you have an opportunity to work
on an independent research project so
the first 45 days would be devoted to
your trading and the next 45 days would
be devoted to your development of an
independent research project
so which includes the literature review
the data set for finalization the
methodology the results interpretation
of those results and then the report
writing and manuscript
so this is the major difference between
the three tenures 45 60 and 90. now as
you can see on my screen that the
pricing here is right now in INR and it
would be mostly for the Asian Community
Etc so for 45 days it is 7500 for 60
days it is uh nine triple nine and then
for 90 days it's 149 15 000. now those
who are from different locations and uh
for example those who are from U.S
they can simply click on this drop down
menu and change their currency into USD
into dollars if someone is from Brazil
they can change into Brazilian currency
and if someone is from Africa they can
change accordingly into naira so here
are few of the currencies which we have
mentioned and according to your uh Place
according to your location you can
change here from this drop down menu for
example have changed it into dollars
right now so the pricing for uh 45 days
in dollars is a dollar 150 for 60 it's
300 and for 90 it's 450. and right now
we are providing everyone with a 50
scholarship on like because of it's like
it's a offer of for the Christmas or the
New Year Eve so if you can I'll just
show you how you can proceed further
with the uh payment you need to Simply
sign up on this learn portal and you can
redirect towards this a link I guess
shubham has already shared the steps you
registered in the chat box so you can
copy paste somewhere in the notes and
you can follow those steps so you need
to Simply click uh here on buy now
button you will be redirected to this
page
and the health the coupon code for the
50 percent is health
50. click on apply
coupon is applied successfully you can
see here the total was dollar 150 after
applying 50 uh coupon the sub the total
amount is dollar 75 you need to fill
here your user details click on this
check box and select the stripe payment
uh more and fill out your card details
and click on this buy now button so this
is how you can you can simply proceed
with the payment checkout so the steps
are really really easy
and um yeah so this was all about the
registration part the fees the
scholarship Etc now if anyone is having
any doubt regarding the registration or
the resources or any kind of question
please feel free to Ping in the chat and
I'll be there to assist you thank you so
much
thank you so much first so we'll wait
for a few few more minutes so that if
the participants are having any queries
we can take them up
yes and also SRI gauri has shared my
shared my email address and the official
contact number of the company here in
the chat box if if anyone is having any
query and at any even point of time they
can they can really mail me at marketing
logic.com or they can contact me at
plus919876-134120 and this number is
active on WhatsApp also
how much is the coupon code to worth
again so it's uh it's 50 discount which
we are giving right now and this uh
coupon code is valid for this month only
because uh for the like we are giving
right now it's a limited offer till
Christmas or New Year that's it in the
January uh there won't be any 50
scholarship so anyone who is interested
in this particular program please uh go
and Avail this opportunity
in this particular month only thank you
thank you so much Parish uh does the
participants are having any other
queries so you can unmute yourself and
ask them as well
I'm sharing uh
contact details once more in the chat
and we will be mailing out today's
webinar recordings to your emails as
well so along the way if you're having
any queries you can reach out to us at
marketingstogic.com uh and we have one
more query from Dr Avinash is Discount
available on INR payment
yes yes yes so whatever like I have
shown different currencies option uh on
the learn portal is it is active on
every currency it's active on INR also
so shubham has already shared the coupon
code that's Health 50. it's h-e-a-l-t
yeah shubham has once again shared the
coupon code you can see in the chat box
it's it is applicable for all the
currencies for INR for dollar for uh
naira for Brazilian for euros every
every currency
you just need to type apply the coupon
code that is Health 50 and health is in
capitals
that's all
thank you sparsh
and I guess we have no other queries
is it held on objects
sorry
[Music]
would you please repeat your query
hello could you please repeat your query
I don't think we
um there was some kind of a disturbance
in between
all right uh the query is
from
um Sayed nawaj is it held on Zoom
so I guess uh side you are asking about
those like sessions
uh so yes it's a it's a virtual program
and we'll be conducting live sessions
through uh via Zoom only we'll be
sharing the calendar invitation to the
participants who will be enrolling for
this program and they can simply join
Zoom ask the questions whatever they
feel so uh like they are having and
depending upon the tenure they have
chosen like 60 or 90 they have the other
opportunities as well of one-on-one
mentorship and the research proposal or
the independent research project
I suppose I answer your question
thank you so much
um thus the participants are having any
other queries
will the recording of the session be
available yes it will be available and
we'll be mailing out to you with the
insights of today's webinar as well
all right so I guess we have no further
queries and with that thank you so much
uh Dr sarkar and to all the participants
for joining today's session
um I guess there was we didn't get the
previous recording yet uh yes we will
mail out the previous webinar recording
as well once more so that for those
participants who have not received it uh
they can check your inbox please check
that uh if it has not gone to the
promotion or spam as well so you can
check those
um as well
and with that thank you everyone for
joining today's webinar and have a great
thank you
thank you
just